let's head to downing street now our
political correspondent rob powell has
just come out of a number 10 briefing
hello to you rob
uh
developments this morning on the
national living wage and also the prime
minister's assessment ahead of cop 26.
let's start with the national living
wage to rise in wednesday's budget
yeah revealed by the treasury uh in the
last five minutes that the national
living wage and the national minimum
wage living wage applies to over 23s the
living wage the minimum wage applies to
everyone that that will
rise the exact amounts um are the living
wage that's the one for older people
goes from eight pounds 91 to nine pounds
fifty an hour so an extra the treasury
says a thousand pounds uh a year for a
full-time worker
and from the first of april as well
young people and apprentices will get
the national minimum wage that's for
people aged 21 and 22 that will go up
to 9 pounds 18
as well so this was broadly expected the
previous chancellor laid out some years
ago that he wanted to see the
national living wage get
up above 10 pounds per hour by around
2024 and it is previously in line with
increases we've had in the past
to the living wage but i think when
rishi sunak the chancellor announces his
budget on wednesday we can expect them
to link this to one of the themes that
we may well hear in that budget around
the cost of living we have seen energy
bills increase we have seen petrol
prices go up and inflation running
higher than it has been and i think you
can expect the chancellor to link this
announcement to
their
ambition to help people
on the lowest wages tackle those rising
costs
of course the traditional critique from
some in business of increases to things
like the minimum wage and the living
wage is that it forces companies to lay
off workers because they can't afford to
pay them more now
experts since then have said there's not
actually any real evidence of that
happening but it does tie into a sort of
broader worry about the government's
plan to try and move to an economy
where people are paid more a high wage
economy that businesses
worry that the way that you pay for
those wage increases is through higher
prices and higher prices
clearly eats into those wage increases
and negates them especially for people
who may not get higher wage increases so
the answer i suspect if it was put to
the chancellor would be that
productivity needs to go up as well and
he would point to things like the three
billion pounds that's been invested to
help people reskill and up skill so that
businesses um can produce more take more
in and are able to pay their employers
more
rob we've also had the prime minister
talking to children earlier on today and
giving a very pessimistic assessment of
the prospects of cop 26. what if downing
street had to say about that
yeah the prime minister's been holding a
press conference with some school pupils
in the last couple of hours
in which he spoke about the climate
conference that's due to begin in the
coming days um in glasgow and actually
he came out with uh probably one of the
more pessimistic sounding readings of
how he thinks preparation and the
ambitions for the cop conference
are are going um he said that he thought
that success at that conference
would be in his words
touch and go and he was very worried
about it as well now we've just had uh
what's the daily briefing where
political journalists go into
a briefing room just up the road at
number nine downing street and are able
to quiz the prime minister's official
spokesperson about whatever they want
and he was asked about that about
whether what the prime minister was
playing at is essentially trying to
manage expectations talk down your
ambitions for the conference so then if
something comes out of it you can claim
success and the prime minister's
spokesperson said that wasn't what was
going on but he also did um admit that
actually uh there were big challenges
for the glasgow conference and the fact
was the fact that we're still working
through the previous climate conference
in paris shows how difficult um this is
so he didn't deny that this is going to
be difficult um but uh said that this
wasn't some sort of media strategy by
the prime minister to manage
expectations i think
there are a few skeptical eyebrows going
uh around among journalists when he said
that though also one of the more unusual
interventions we had from the prime
minister in that press conference with
school pupils
was a suggestion that to rebalance
nature perhaps we could think about
feeding humans to animals
now as you would expect the prime
minister spokesperson was asked about
that as well but said that
that was not to be taken seriously so
not a new policy from the government
feeding humans to animals
a journalist cynical who would ever have
thought it rob powell in downing street
for us thank you